east nevada aviator john lear's death
tuesday has sent ripples throughout the
worlds of aviation and conspiracy
theories lear was widely known for his
claims about ufos in area 51 but also
for a lifetime of daring exploits in
everything that could fly the eight news
now i-team's george knapp looks back at
a colorful life
most people think i'm absolutely nuts
and that's okay with me john lear didn't
mind when people attacked his wild
stories in fact he reveled in it he came
to be known as the godfather of
conspiracies but anyone who was given a
tour of his jam-packed den knew there
was a lot more to leer than tall tales
and that's the secret base there those
walls were a museum of his life pictures
with the famous and infamous of planes
he had flown secret places and projects
he'd investigated regret wasn't a word
he was known to use would you do it the
same way exactly the same way determined
to carve out his own path lear dove into
aviation becoming an accomplished pilot
at a young age eventually setting
multiple world records in all manner of
planes his daredevil life came at a cost
serious injuries caused by plane crashes
he shouldn't have survived during the
vietnam era he flew cargo planes for the
c.i.a and continued to court danger by
flying in and out of other hot spots in
the mid 80s he started hearing stories
about a ufo cover-up and not
surprisingly jumped in with both feet
making various media appearances to
discuss his ideas the people are
abducted they're taken up into a saucer
good evening this is john lear in march
1989 he accompanied a small group to the
outskirts of area 51. three wednesday
nights in a row they watched a glowing
disc rise above the mountains over
papua's dry lake
the person who initiated the desert
outing was a scientist who claimed he
worked at papua's on flying saucers that
scientist was interviewed live on
television in may 1989 from lear's
driveway a tale that spread around the
world nine
flying saucers flying discs later that
year the identity of lear's friend was
made public bob lazar's claims put area
51 on the map in his later years lear's
health declined he could no longer fly
but continued to share stories about
increasingly outrageous conspiracies the
crazy stories don't obscure what was an
amazing life to the end lear figured
he'd be vindicated believe me when i
tell you you may not you may not find
out in a month a year
five years or ten years but you'll look
back at what i'm telling you now
and you'll say to yourself
my gosh the son of a gun was right
george knapp 8 news now
lear instructed his daughter daughter to
issue this message after his death tell
them john lear has embarked on his next
adventure we have more information about
lear on our website